♪ ♪
>> President Trump: MICHAEL
COHEN IS A LINE, HE'S A WEAK
PERSON, WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO
IS GET A REDUCED SENTENCE.
WE WERE THINKING ABOUT BUILDING
A BUILDING, I DECIDED ULTIMATELY
NOT TO DO IT.
EVEN IF HE WAS RIGHT, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
IF I WAS ALLOWED TO DO WHATEVER
I WANTED DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
>> HE WAS AFRAID OF THE TRUTH
AND HE DOESN'T WANT MUELLER TO
UNCOVER IT.
>> IF ANYTHING THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID IS TRUE, WHY ARE ALL OF HIS
CLOSEST ASSOCIATES BEING FOUND
GUILTY OF LYING ABOUT THEIR TIES
TO RUSSIA?
>> Bret: WE ARE TOLD THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT,
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN KNEW WHAT ABOUT IT ON
MONDAY THAT MICHAEL COHEN WAS
GOING TO APPEAR IN COURT AND
PLEAD GUILTY TO LYING TO
CONGRESS.
HE MADE FALSE STATEMENTS TO BOTH
THE HOUSE AND SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEES TO
MINIMIZE LINKS BETWEEN THE
MOSCOW PROJECT AND INDIVIDUAL
TRUMP AND TWO GIVES FALSE
IMPRESSIONS THAT IT ENDED BEFORE
THE IOWA CAUCUSES IN THE HOPES
OF LIMITING THE ONGOING RUSH
INVESTIGATIONS.
THE MOSCOW PROJECT WAS DISCUSSED
MULTIPLE TIMES WITHIN THE
COMPANY AND DID NOT END IN
JANUARY 2016.
INSTEAD, IT WAS APPROXIMATELY
JUNE 2016 COHEN ENDED INDIVIDUAL
BELIEVED TO BE FELIX SATYR
DISCUSSED APPROVAL FOR THE
MOSCOW PROJECT.
BACK IN JANUARY OF 2017,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED THIS HE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT IT BUT WE DID
THIS: "RUSSIA HAS NEVER TRIED TO
USE LEVERAGE OVER ME.
I HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIA, NO DEALS, NO LOANS, NO
NOTHING."
FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY ARI FLEISCHER
AND MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR
WRITER AT THE FEDERALIST.
YOUR IMPRESSIONS TODAY, HOW
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> AS CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER USED
TO SAY, IT FEELS LIKE A COVER-UP
OF SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT A
CRIME.
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE IF
THIS PROJECT ENDED IN JANUARY OF
2017 OR JANUARY OF 2016 OR JUNE?
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE AND WITH THE
MOTIVE?
AND I CAN'T SEE ANY MOTIVE HERE,
WHY WOULD HE DO IT?
THERE IS NO UNDERLYING CRIME,
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG, IT MIGHT
BE UNSAVORY FOR UP PERSON
RUNNING FOR THE PRESIDENT TO DO
BUSINESS ABROAD BUT IT'S NOT A
CRIME.
>> IF YOU WANT TO NUMBER WHETHER
PRESIDENT TRUMP THINKS IT'S A
SERIOUS ISSUE, LOOK AT THE
RESPONSE.
HE CLEARLY THINKS IT'S A SERIOUS
STORY AND I THINK THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN JANUARY AND
JUNE BECAUSE BY JUNE IT WAS
CLEAR THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
GOING TO BE THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT.
AT THAT TIME HIS PERSONAL
LAWYERS REACHING OUT TO A
KREMLIN OFFICIAL ON A PRIVATE
BUSINESS DEAL AND TO HELP
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT IS A WEB THAT IS BEING
REVEALED BY SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER, IT'S NOT OVER YET, THIS
ISN'T THE LESS DISCLOSURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT'S A
TROUBLING CONTEXT TO LOOK AT
TODAY'S PLEA DEAL.
>> IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS SET UP TO
INVESTIGATE TREASONOUS COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA TO STEAL AN
ELECTION, NOT TO INVESTIGATE
WHETHER DONALD TRUMP IS A
GLOBALIST BUSINESSMAN.
IT'S GOOD TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LYING TO
CONGRESS.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE WE'VE SEEN SO
FEW PEOPLE HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN
THIS RUSSIA STORY.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO BUILT THE
ENTIRE RUSSIA DOSSIER WAS
REFERRED BY THE HEAD OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ALMOST A YEAR AGO BECAUSE THEY
KNEW HE LIED TO THE FBI.
WHEN SIMPSON GAVE TESTIMONY, HE
WAS HIRED TO SET UP THE WHOLE
RUSSIA STORY -- HE GAVE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS AT ODDS WITH
WHAT BRUCE OHR
IT'S IMPORTANT EVERYONE BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, IT'S NOT JUST THEM,
YOU LOOK AT JAMES CLAPPER WHO
LIED ABOUT SPYING ON EVERYONE,
JOHN BRENNAN LIED ABOUT SPYING,
HILLARY CLINTON LIED ABOUT
WHETHER CLASSIFIED SYSTEMS WORK.
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
LYING IS A GOOD THING, IT SHOULD
BE DONE OVERALL.
>> Bret: DONALD TRUMP AT THE
TIME UNDER OATH AS HE'S TWEETING
THAT WE HAD NO TIES, NO NOTHING,
NO LOANS OBVIOUSLY HE'S NOT
UNDER OATH WHEN HE'S TELLING
REPORTERS THAT HE HAD NOTHING
EVER TO DO WITH RUSSIA.
>> HE DIDN'T HAVE BUSINESS DEALS
WITH RUSSIA.
>> Bret: HE DIDN'T DEVELOP BUT
IT WAS BEING DISCUSSED AS IT
CONTINUED ON UNTIL JUNE AS
OPPOSED TO JANUARY.
MY POINT IS, IS THERE SOMETHING
HERE AS FAR AS MONEY?
WE DON'T KNOW.
DEUTSCHE BANK, GOT RATED FOR THE
PANAMA PAPERS TODAY.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TIED AT
ALL BUT IF THERE'S A MONEY LINK
HERE, IS IT BEYOND THE LYING TO
CONGRESS AND IS RUSSIA HOLDING
SOMETHING OVER DONALD TRUMP'S
HEAD?
>> YOU JUST USE THE MAGIC WORDS
WE SHOULD ALL ABIDE BY.
THE PROBLEM I HAVE WITH THIS
TOWN IS IF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHAT DOESN'T STOP THEM FROM
TALKING.
THEY MAKE THE WORST ACCUSATIONS
IN PUBLIC LIFE WOULD THEY DO NOT
LIKE EVEN IF THEY DON'T KNOW THE
UNDERLYING FACTS, IT'S WHAT
SENATOR SCHUMER DID TODAY, IT'S
WHAT SENATOR WARNER DID TODAY.
>> Bret: I'M ASKING YOU WHERE
POTENTIALLY COULD IT GO?
>> I'M NOT WILLING TO SPECULATE
BECAUSE ONLY BOB MUELLER WILL
KNOW THAT AND I DON'T THINK ANY
OF US TO TRY TO PUT OURSELVES IN
THIS B.S. SHE AND SPECULATE ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER.
IF MUELLER HAS GOT THE GOODS, HE
WILL DELIVER THE GOODS, IF HE
DOESN'T THIS TOWN OWES
DONALD TRUMP AN APOLOGY.
>> Bret: IS THERE A SENSE THAT
IT COMES TO A HEAD?
>> THERE'S A SENSE THAT ROBERT
MUELLER SEEMS TO BE CLOSER AND
CLOSER OF MAKING A REPORT ON
SOME ASPECTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION BUT THE ASPECTS
INVOLVING PRESIDENT TRUMP
DIRECTLY THAT WE'VE BEEN SO
CURIOUS ABOUT -- THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN JANUARY, THAT IS
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE ARE GOING
TO GAIN THE POWER TO HAVE
HEARINGS AND DEMAND TESTIMONY
AND SUBPOENA DOCUMENTS.
THE QUESTION YOU JUST RAISED
ABOUT DID RUSSIA LAUNDER MONEY,
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S BEEN SPECULATED ABOUT.
THAT'S A SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT
ADAM SCHIFF THE NEW CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
SAID TODAY HE IS GOING TO START
PURSUING AS SOON AS HE IS ABLE.
>> WE DON'T START WITH SAYING
HERE IS THE PERSON FIND ME THE
CRIME, WE LOOK AT THE CRIME AND
DETERMINE WHAT SHOULD BE DONE
ABOUT IT.
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH CRAZY
SPECULATION WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE
OF A CRIME AND WE HAD ACTUALLY
HAVE EVIDENCE OF ALL SORTS OF
THINGS, CRIMINAL LICKING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, LYING TO
A FISA COURT, THEY AREN'T BEING
WORRIED ABOUT BY PEOPLE WHO
THINK IF WE JUST KEEP DIGGING,
MAYBE WE CAN FINALLY GET TRUMP.
HOW ABOUT WE DEAL WITH ACTUAL
CRIMES?
>> Bret: I'M GOING TO PLAY
THIS PROTECTION OF SPECIAL
COUNSEL MOLAR, FIRST FOR
MINORITY LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> THIS IDEA THAT WE DON'T NEED
TO PASS LEGISLATION TO PROTECT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL INTERFERE WITH THE
INVESTIGATION IS FLAT-OUT
ABSURD.
>> OUR JOB HERE SHOULD BE TO
PROTECT ROBERT MUELLER SO HE CAN
DO HIS JOB.
NOT FOR HIM, BUT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> BOB MUELLER HAS BEEN LEFT
ALONE, I THINK HE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE LEFT ALONE.
IF I WAS STRESSED ABOUT BOB
MUELLER, I WOULD DO SOMETHING.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT HIM.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID HE'S NOT FIRING BOB
MUELLER.
MATT WHITAKER HAS SAID HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY PLANS TO GET
RID OF BOB MUELLER.
THERE IS AN EFFORT ON
CAPITOL HILL TO PROTECT BOB
MUELLER.
>> FROM WHAT?
IF DONALD TRUMP AN ACTIVE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MATT WHITAKER
WERE A THREAT, WHY DID HE GET A
PLEA AGREEMENT WITH MICHAEL:
COHEN.
NO ONE IS CUTTING HIS BUDGET, NO
ONE'S SAYING YOU ARE LAID OFF.
IT'S AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL MOVE IN
THE FIRST PLACE AS SOMEBODY WHO
USED TO WORK IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
CONGRESS DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER
TO TELL THE PRESIDENT YOU CAN OR
CANNOT FIRE SOMEBODY WHO IS AN
INFERIOR OFFICER IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, IT'S